bisher war robert morris ein eher
unbekannter kommunalpolitiker doch diese
bilder machen ihn jetzt bundesweit
bekannt ein cdu mann bei einer
neonazi-demo im jahr 2011 nimmt der
damals 19-jährige hier als ordner teil
und nicht nur das bis heute hat robert
morris eine schwarze sonne wie hier auf
den arm tätowiert drei übereinander
liegende hakenkreuze ein klares
erkennungszeichen der rechten szene
dazu kommt bis zum wochenende war moritz
mitglied beim umstrittenen verein unit
ernst auf den öffentlichen druck hin ist
er jetzt ausgetreten ich bezweifle dass
das man sich so hundertprozentig innern
kann wenn man diese meinung einmal hat
er also machen seiner jugend schon
sachen die man später im moment schon
wieder nicht mehr zusteht und von daher
wenn er sagt er ist da jetzt weg worden
und hat ist ja nicht mehr in der szene
drin oder so keine kontakte mehr für
mich okay ich bin absolut dagegen und es
ist für mich nicht verständlich dass
einer der die nazi richtung geht
wirklich dann politiker sein darf der
kreisverband von robert morris hat
entschieden kein ausschluss die
entscheidung bekräftigt auch der
generalsekretär
wir haben klipp und klar gesagt dass es
für uns ein riesen problem ist was er
dort verursacht hat und er hat darum
gebeten eine zweite chance auf bewährung
hier zu bekommen zu zeigen dass er mit
diesen menschen auch überhaupt nichts
mehr zu tun hat die koalitionspartner
spd und grüne sehen das ganz anders
schon am wochenende forderten sie eine
abgrenzung der cdu von rechts und
drohten mit dem ende der koalition in
sachsen anhalt in einer pressemitteilung
fragten die grünen provokativ wie viele
hakenkreuze haben platz in der cdu sie
erwarten von der partei klar macht dass
rechtsextremismus bei ihr keinen platz
hat dass jemand der mit einem hakenkreuz
tattoo auf dem ellenbogen bis heute dort
tätig ist nicht als funktionärin
verantwortung stehen kann
nicht zum ersten mal rutscht die
landes-cdu nach rechts erst im juni
sprachen sich die beiden vize
fraktionschefs in einer denkschrift
dafür aus das soziale mit dem nationalen
zu versöhnen und schließen eine debatte
über eine mögliche koalition mit der afg
an
also es gibt einen flügel der möchte ein
aufeinander zu bewegen dass der rechte
flügel um die mitte cdu die möchte das
nicht ich möchte den strecken
abgrenzungskurs und diese strategische
frage über die ausrichtung der union die
ist nach wie vor in sachsen anhalt nicht
entschieden
noch ist der fall moritz in der cdu
nicht abgeschlossen
für donnerstag hat die landesspitze alle
kreischefs nach magdeburg eingeladen um
zu diskutieren ob ein verbleib von
moritz in der partei die richtige
entscheidung war